what a great show we have here today oh
my god you're gonna be wondering why
we're dressed the way we are and to be
honest with you we're still wondering
yes but it's fun we're talking about
eagles we're talking about robots we're
talking about a whole bunch of stuff sex
yeah all that stuff today yeah that was
fun that was a fun fun one you guys are
going to love it it's going to be
awesome um
where can people see yourself well you
could see me in vegas on july 15th uh at
the version of the theater at the
version you could see me this is what
when's this coming out
well i'm then i played the beacon
already so god bless you this week
coming up is the el cajon theater in san
diego on the 21st and the wilton theater
in los angeles on the 22nd and then of
course if i haven't yet we are
announcing phoenix atlanta uh seattle
portland vancouver more florida dates uh
sacramento uh san jose all these things
are coming up i have announced already
they're coming out any day so stay tuned
they're coming out stay looney tuned and
for me christy comedy.com you can see me
i'm in phoenix on may 26th i am in
austin texas at the vulcan gas company
on may 24th and uh i have my netflix
special out called special weshy um it's
out baby christy comedy.com and uh merch
is out merch is out go to our websites
to get the merch patrons coming
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey baby i got me a
chrysler
[Applause]
[Music]
together
[Music]
hey babe how you doing
uh nothing man you know i um we're
lounging today we're hanging out having
a good time we got our terrycloth
leisure on today even though it was a
couple weeks so i just got back from
coachella flight got delayed nice
i just came back from mexico city wow
look at us flank delay you uh yeah man i
um
i had a good time at coachella i did um
i never let me ask you a question please
please are you a guy yeah at this point
in your life as far as i know i am
biological mail yeah buy a lodge are you
a guy that you ever will you ever want
to go to a music festival again in your
life okay so i used to be all about
about it
and now i'm like do i want to stand
amongst people
chest to chest in heat standing in the
dirt all day long
port-a-potties usually those festivals
are out in nice weather got it i thought
you meant you were in heat wow
depending on what time of the day it is
i am also in here uh i don't think i
ever want to do it again i think it's a
young man's game
and i'll i'll go to one if i'm like
maybe like if there's a bleachers or
like a section i could sit in we're
gonna have a little respite right from
from these these these people getting
hosed down now
just for hydration i can't do no thank
you i also now i don't want to go to
music festival anymore but i'll watch
from afar um also shout out jafar from
aladdin yeah i oh i want uh i don't want
to go to a crowded bar anymore if i see
your bars crowded i'm gonna say no thank
you and it's no disrespect i know people
want to go out they won't have a good
time not not for me i'd like to be in
bed by 10 o'clock seven nights a week
now i i actually like midnight is my
time ten's a little early but that's
because i was always a real night owl so
even midnight for me but now i i value a
full night's sleep
more than anything me too more than
anything me too i love sleep i love my
bed i love staying i sleep sleep sleep
write in the comments right now do you
also
love a good night's sleep more than
anything and we could do hashtag that
hashtag me too
uh
[Laughter]
well yeah we won't when we search for
the answers yeah it's gonna be a mixed
bag but yeah uh but you guys might see
some coachella oh is that me on the yeah
that's me on the left that coachella
right there in the yellow that's
actually neat what a great ass that man
has wanna see her there he is there he
is oh that's a male that's a guy
i have to be honest with you
very very nice uh man's ass i mean yeah
i don't really
mine doesn't look like that i mine has
pimples cellulite and a skin tag that's
what everybody's looks like i think i
think he did some work to his ass no i
just think that yeah i don't know who
knows i mean yeah
yeah there's zero part of me and it's
not because of that i love his alphabet
i mean if you covered his head i would
think that's a like i gotta be honest
female uh
bottom i i still say lizzo ward better
yeah so you have seen lizzo's i saw her
getting on a plane recently with her
yes she sells [ __ ] pants yes genius
that's what it is genius amazing and
naturally should we do asset shops for
him i think so because i was just going
to say like that's another thing another
reason why i'm upset that kane i'm still
upset about kane tanaka because she
would have been the perfect model for
lizzo's new clothes i agree i would love
to see uh king tanaka in a lizzo number
oh and answers tanaka oh come on love it
i love it
uh we love kane
kane tanaka versus everybody t-shirts
available in the merch store
portion of the proceeds going to charity
uh in japan yeah we're picking a local
we're going to see if we can pick a
local charity in our area we'll announce
that this would be fine we just gotta do
the proper research because we just
figured this out if we can't and if we
can't find a
japanese foundation that we like we will
donate to a local sushi restaurant
something something we'll do someone's
getting donations
or we'll donate it to ginseng arizona
iced tea we'll do something that we know
kane would have wanted all donated just
to old people well donate to a check if
you got a charity that benefits people
who are old as [ __ ] that's what we do
only old as [ __ ] though
don't don't you dare become a judge with
a charity of people in their 90s don't
you damn
it's old as [ __ ]
if there's a chariot i want to make a
charity called oldest buck and it
benefits elderly people it helps get
them into homes yo you know what i think
that would be a great idea buy zip code
by zip code it goes to the oldest person
in their zip code all over the country
all over the country it's called old as
[ __ ] old as [ __ ] and it helps them yes
and and in every zip code they come
forward they're like i think i'm the
oldest in the zip code and they get they
get help well yes yes a death
scholarship yeah basically it is edit
this part out because it's a great idea
we're going to be the next elon musk
yeah
honestly it'll go to their insurers yeah
i love it
and then that's what they say we're
buying you insurance and we'll spell it
e-n-s-u-r
insurance insurance oh we gotta partner
up with ensure
edit these parts out to let's go
no honestly if i saw a playful charity
that was called old as [ __ ] and i read
it goes yo you donate and it goes it
gets split up and it gets divided to
every oh the oldest person in every zip
code i would be like that is amazing i'm
donating in short if you're listening
and we know that you are yeah we know
that you why don't you team up with the
hay bay podcast and let's get this thing
off the ground if you really care about
old people in their digestive system
that's true then you'll partner up with
hey babe and end shawn give them end
assurance from the oldest [ __ ] charity
it's no it's a no-brainer yeah old as
[ __ ] sponsored by ensure yeah ants yeah
that's it and the charity will be
olaf.com like the character from frozen
o-l-a-f o as [ __ ] oh yeah o
o l o a f o o l a f that's good i mean
don't i mean this is this is
i would like to do this yeah i don't
know what's behind starting a charity
though
that might be take a lot of leg work
you've never worked for a charity before
i've worked with a charity yeah i've
worked with with charities but i don't
think i've ever worked for one or ever
launching one launching like a non-prof
it might be involved
maybe maybe we can do an old as [ __ ]
like uh uh gofundme or something of the
idea then take all those proceeds and
make a donation to an old charity but i
really believe that if you're the oldest
person in your zip code
and you can prove it well you get
rewarded now there's no reason to take
care of yourself why would you want to
be the oldest person what do you mean
right now without a reward why would you
want to be the oldest person in your
neighborhood you wouldn't yeah right
you're saying this is this is amazing
yeah this is pro
oldies yeah this is pro this is pro old
yeah okay i like i really do like
charity i'd love to do it
a lot of old people if anybody uh one of
our listeners deals with charities has
any experience of charities and can help
us kind of
float this thing uh email pimp and put
in the subject line
old as [ __ ] right okay only if you can
help us really really really
anybody else who writes as old as [ __ ]
and then sends something else it will be
discarded
and also people should be able to submit
their family members who are oldest yes
and and also if you have a family member
and a zip code
put in that subject old as [ __ ] put the
zip code and then their name and age
yeah because we will get them their cash
yep
i like it a saudi prince bought airline
seats for all 80 of his falcons so if
you got on that flight
holy
[ __ ]
yeah i mean it's a seat full of falcons
in their seats it's a plane full of
falcons in their seats in their proper
seats yeah sitting down
how is this allowed
imagine having a middle seat between
falcons
do they have to have masks on they're
hogging they're hogging the armors with
their wings
oh my god they asked me they're pecking
out my penis yeah it's like oh great
this guy these things have six foot
wingspans this will be comfortable i
think a falcon could gouge your
everything out yeah i was next to an
eagle at a corporate gig i did about
three weeks ago and it was pretty scary
that eagle oh i actually i had a falcon
on my arm in the show and at any moment
i felt like i could take my life at will
sure yeah i i will tell you something
growing up it started in high school uh
we did we would play this game with my
friends where it was like they they
would say okay they would give me an
animal or a scenario versus me in a
fight to the death who would win and
everybody would weigh in on it and it
started off with a bald eagle versus me
that was the first one we ever did okay
and i maintained
through high school and 20 years after
that that in a one-on-one in an arena
locked in an arena in a fight to the
death to the death right i would be able
to kill a bald eagle and i was met with
resistance from everyone they said if
the bald eagle wanted you dead it would
fly down and slice your neck open in two
seconds with its talons and i say that
could happen but it would need to be
laser accurate and i could block myself
if i see the thing coming i'm not saying
i wouldn't get [ __ ] up but if it was a
fight to the death if the eagles coming
down if i get a hold of the eagle i know
that the eagle is strong but if i got a
hold of the eagle yeah and i snap a wing
or choke it by the neck i don't care
what talons the eel has yeah i'll tell
that though so i'm thinking like maybe i
take a slice or a cut or something but
then when it tries to jump on me if i
just grab that [ __ ] eagle and turn
and put all my weight on it and just
snap a wing now he's grounded he's
hopping around grounded now yeah and now
what's he going to do he's going to hop
up and try to slice
i can still block i'm not saying i won't
lose an eye i'm not saying i won't lose
a gallon of blood but in a fight to the
ultimate death i think i had kind of it
might be even money and everyone told me
i was crazy but i'll tell you now right
now i think i might have been crazy now
no dude you outweigh the eagle you
outweigh the eagles yeah by a hundred
plus pounds yeah i don't know how much
an eagle weighs i know you weigh about a
buck eighty yeah well thank you so much
you're so sweet yeah so there's so much
for that right let's say an eagle might
weigh a hundred and what saying what is
an eagle what is an eagle way third
eagle way what is an eagle what are you
doing watching an eagle attack at
full-grown deer and win oh let's watch
it watch that
i truthfully think i can beat an eagle
to death with a wiffle ball bat
i don't know if yeah you know what i
believe that all you need to do is
strike 15 pounds
i can beat that thing to death then why
does everyone think i'm going down
immediately
let's see
gary is all [ __ ] don't i don't want to
be a anything
bird is a big bird yeah look at this is
that the deer there's a deer there
that's a full deer
yeah but so the eagle's 15 pounds and
it's taking out a full deer how did that
happen
i guess the the force of a wolf
look at this eagle attacks a wolf
no if it kills a wolf
what is that a native american the guy
holding the eagle
he's going to let the eagle go off the
horse oh this is like this is involved
[Laughter]
it's like a triathlon this is an
interesting sport yo turn around wolf
turn around the wolf that's the good
wolf look at this thing
or is that the bad wolf oh my god oh my
god oh my god so what is it oh my god
get your neck
wha what what does this eagle think like
this eagle doesn't think the the wolf
could turn around and bite bite its head
off
two eagles are attacking it
the one eagle's doing pretty good
yo honestly
i'm so proud that that is our national
don't tell me that's the wolf down there
it killed the wolf it murdered the wolf
it murdered a wolf
couldn't the wolf turn around and bite
it do you think you're stronger than a
wolf
did it truthfully kill that wolf i mean
it's done dude when the talents come
down is it like you're getting stabbed
with five knives is a bald eagle pretty
much just a flying version of edward
scissorhands
oh my god
is that what it is honestly though
remember though look at that look at
that guy's cuts remember i will know
that it's coming at me that was a
surprise attack on that wolf yeah i will
know i don't you have to have a weapon
you could only have your bare hands you
can only have my bare hands
right
i don't know man after seeing it kill a
wolf because it might get your neck and
head and kill you immediately yeah but
if it's coming at me
you know i could juke bob how are you
gonna hit it
i don't need to hit it i need to get a
hold of it
if i get a hold of it it's yeah
look at that look at that dude you're
not going to kill that oh whoa that it
has full whoa
like razor blade that looks like a
lion's claws i mean people in prison get
stabbed to death with spoons right
that's like four eight shivs
yeah let's see can you play it is that
is that eagle dead but again i'm saying
i definitely know i'm getting sliced up
but all i'm saying is is the eagle
winning a hundred percent of the time
yes if it was if there was a hundred
fights you're telling me i won't kill
the eagle some of that well that equals
a lot right now you're saying there's a
chance there's a chance
that's all i'm saying
but there's also a chance you could be
president
that would be sick
come on pimp you took the wind out of my
sails
that would be sick would i make a good
president what would you pre do you have
like an idea of what a slogan might be
no pressure no pressure
vote for no pressure everybody back off
interesting let's just take it lightly
you know
i'll try to befriend every country
i'll go over there my slogan would be
hey babe yeah i'd go hey babe yeah
to the country every morning i focused
less on politics and more about personal
relations same with me you know politics
would kind of take a little bit of a
backseat some people might have a
problem with that but this is not the
way i'm the president that's the way i
want to rule the country yeah
no i'm 60
and you see you see you put time into
people you invest in people and you get
returns
nobody's investing in other people
nobody invested in other people
people all they want to do is invest in
crypto how about other people how about
other people you tell me who my foreign
policy is like my foreign policy is
going to be like every single country is
going to be bffs with us my my foreign
policy would be french fries for
everybody legalize it
why doesn't someone do something like
that
because nobody's thinking if
it was on the news today that biden was
handing out free fries to everyone in
the world wouldn't you be like i kind of
like that i kind of like i can't i can't
hate on that i vote for him yeah other
unless he starts to hand out free french
fries to everyone in this country he's
not getting my vote
yo no lie i love shop fine oh i know you
do we talk about shopping
no i'm telling you i ain't got no lie
when i say i love shopify shopify is
changing the game shopify what it does
is it gives entrepreneurs like yourself
the resources once reserved for big
business
so now upstarts and startups and
established businesses alike can sell
everywhere synchronize online and
in-person sales and effortlessly stay
informed it's the sound of another sale
on shopify the all-in-one platform to
start run and grow your business this is
legit a necessity for us if you're
running a business out there you can't
really get around shopify that's right
you know you just you just can't like
you just have to go
through shopify just like scaling your
business i mean you gotta do it it's a
journey of endless possibilities and
shopify helps you get there that's what
it is baby i love how shopify has the
tools and resources that make it easy
for any business to succeed uh from down
the street to around the globe shopify
powers millions of businesses millions
from first sale to full scale i love it
and right now um you'll gain first of
all it's more than a store shopify too
it grows with you this is possibility
powered by shopify right now if you go
to shopify.com
hey babe all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com hey babe right now
shopify.com slash hey babe
are those from blenders no
they should be because blenders eyewear
i know first of all they're the only i i
stop i i only now wear sunglasses when
i'm driving when i'm going out because
i'm like oh you shouldn't be getting oh
i got a pair of blenders i use it when i
drive now
that's all i do i got my uh my sunglass
prescription exactly yeah yeah i love
blenders um chase fish are starter
blenders everybody loves chase by
selling the beachy shades out of a
backpack while doubling as a surf
instructor on pacific beach the kid just
had a dream yeah and the dream is coming
what was his goal his goal was to create
an adventurous mid-priced eyewear option
that has the same cool factor as your
leading styles unlike the big expensive
brands
you probably lost you probably smashed
them in the past blenders are actually
affordable so you're not gonna cry as
much when the inevitable happens it's
what it is and listen it's not just
sunglasses okay blunders has
prescription glasses
readers and blue lights as well as a
snow collection with goggles and
accessories live life and forward motion
with blenders today right now you're
going to get 15 off your blender's
purchase where do they go what do they
got to do to get 50 off their blender's
purchase you got to go to visit you
gotta visit
blenderseyeware.com and enter the promo
code hey babe vip wow
that's blenderseyeware.com
code hey babe vip for 15
off blenders rocked with pride worldwide
nobody's getting my vote unless they
hand out french fries
um
me versus a third grade class was
another one no third grade class i think
that you would easily i think you kill
everyone including a teacher fifth grade
fifth grade now we're getting tougher
fifth grade you 30 kids fifth grade
class let me ask you this
what neighborhood
of the fifth grade that's an important
question average neighborhood there's no
there's no there's nobody in that like
no young gang members no one's uh no one
crazy no weapons no big kids there's
nobody that's got two kids no no if
there's a kid that's in the 90th
percentile and height and weight he's in
there
it's a numbers game how many kids in the
class 30 kids 30 5th grade kids now they
fight to the death fight to the death no
no no until submission
i was going to say you'd have to start
killing fifth grade
that's not it was the fight that's with
the eagle to submission with the kids
here's what i think i think every kid
i'd love to watch you put a kid in an
arm oh i'm definitely yeah well he's
right there he's like i used to love you
i think every single kid i think every
kid
is is tapping out at that one clean nice
shot yeah whether it's a kick a punch
whether i break a hand i think you know
if i take one swing and hit a kid
anywhere in the fifth grade he's gonna
be like i am now not joining the rest of
this why is this not the second season
of squid games
this should be it should be it you to
fight an eagle fight a fifth grade class
a third grade class i now there was
debates on whether i'm allowed to have a
cup or not and i will tell you uh for
the fifth grade classes no cup they
could also bite me
but again i still think
i still think as long as i keep my hands
in a fist
and i just just keep popping them and
kicking them as they come well it
depends i because think about how many
fifth graders can attack me at the same
time there's only a certain amount all
30 can't attack me at the same time
right right well i mean listen it
depends i mean i you know i was a
pediatric physical therapist and you
know i worked with mentally and
physically handicapped kids and i one
time in the school i was working on long
island they had like a panic room like a
padded room and um one of the students
who was i believe in fourth or fifth
grade was having like a meltdown um you
know
a child with autism was having like a
meltdown and he was you know uh he would
buy it and he would get a little
aggressive and he beat the [ __ ] out of
me
like
truly like like i
i could do nothing like i was but you
couldn't touch him no when you go in
that pan a room you do anything you can
to subdue them i mean i'm not gonna
punch a kid in the face right but
i'm saying i'm going to punch i was in
my mid-20s and i i was getting thrown
around by this kid he was a strong kid
heavy kid
so i would have to go for him first you
have to go for him first i would knock
out the handicapped children first i
could go for the bigger kids first
by the time i get to the last few kids
they're just going to back out without
touching me yeah some of them might take
i think i take a fifth grade class but
i'm told i would be surprised because it
will it will take some eighth grade
class you'll die if they hang on me if
they start hanging on me and then one
kid just comes and clips you do they
have weapons
nobody's got weapons no i think fifth
grade is tough if they get me on the
floor i still think it's pretty tough i
think ultimately i'd be eighth grade
class i think i'm done and they know
it's coming
yeah
we were gonna fight each other okay okay
eighth grade class i think i'm done i
agree with that
because
at that point you know
eight nine kids are holding my arms you
know they might they might get me there
it's it it'd be debatable but i think
i'm done i think i'm done with an eighth
grade class um
it was a room a room full of chihuahuas
uh i don't get to wear shoes
i think i still have it i think i punt
them all over the room yes i think you
start killing them one by one one kick
one kick i punt them against them i
think if you just get a running kick if
it's a room full of them you might kill
four at a shot
like you might kill like you might get
you yeah i might get into some nice i
might get some nice mileage out of no
shoes those gotta suck yeah because they
i mean they're gonna be coming at me
they're gonna be nipping at my my
piggies
yeah because if they get you down they
can get your neck you could be done
yeah
uh and how many chihuahuas i'll say 100.
that's a lot of chill hours man
that's a lot of chihuahuas okay so you
you open the door
and it's like one of those old school
like freaking coliseums right and
there's a hundred chihuahuas right and
they're like all right place your bets
it's krista stefano versus 102 hours
do you think that you might
lose and i'm going to die if i don't
kill them all
killing is tough
let's take it like killing
killing out of it like
it's like a fight to the death but no no
no just just whoever submits first
will you be honest how is it going to
know how to submit you know just in
general they back down
right you might you might they might not
you might have to either fight you know
what you might have [ __ ] up all hundreds
because i might have to do something to
show my mean business like i might go in
there instead of trying to kill all
hundred i might beat up a hundred i
might go in there and kill one and start
eating in front of the other ones yeah
oh my god
it's it's fair play anything that's fine
you understand yeah they might they
might honestly they know instinctually
that that's not good yeah they bought it
you might make a good example they're
like he's loco
okay okay so i think i think right now
i think you have the best chance of
surviving uh the third grade class even
more so than the did you always just
because i think they keep pecking at you
you're going to just want to be like
also if they there's plenty of arteries
in the ankle they nip and artery in the
ankle you'll bleed out really absolutely
okay
your femoral artery up here if they get
up here they can jump and start hanging
off your legs how much do they have with
clenched strength who knows they're
fighting to the death too you know if
one grabs me and it seems to be hanging
off of me i mean what's the heaviest
chihuahua you've ever seen heavy showers
what 12 pounds that that seems like even
a lot to me i think the heaviest
chihuahua of all time has got to be
seven pounds what about like a teacup
chihuahua it's like a half a pound 28
pounds what that's that's not a no
longer
i got news for you that's no longer oh
my god let me tell you something right
now that's not
that's
it looks
i i feel spammed for it
i think you found your next game show
yeah
finding the fattest chihuahua you really
oh my [ __ ] cat judge uncle can
look i would say that the lightest
chihuahua and the heaviest job will pose
zero threat i think you've got to look
for the middle of the roadshow
your average chihuahua you ever played
the old nintendo ice hockey game from
the original nintendo and you had to
pick between four players a skinny guy
who skated fast a medium guy who was
average at everything and a big [ __ ]
fat guy who skated very slow but took a
slap shot like your mother's uncle right
and and you had to you could choose four
skinny got any combination i used to do
with a skinny guy uh because
two skinnies because i needed speed and
uh they won face-offs then one medium
and one fat that's who you'd go yeah but
if so if a fat guy touched the skinny
guy he'd go flying
i don't remember it oh yeah i mean what
a hella you could never do that now no
just have a fat guy it's hysterical it's
like a cartman yeah a little like stick
figure and two metal guys
wow gracie the chihuahua whose weight
spiraled out of control at her heaviest
gave it at 42 pounds do you understand
what 40 pounds is on
legs do you understand that there might
be a [ __ ] it almost can't walk honestly
it's almost like it's a beached whale
why are we not coming up with an idea
for a shower youtube series
about obese chihuahuas and we call it my
40 pound life
[Laughter]
they crane lifted them out of this yeah
yeah
oh my god my 45 my 40-pound life about
obese two hours i mean that would that
not kill on the animal planet that's a
really do we do it do you have to deal
with the animal planet i have is it are
they with discovery who knows yeah do we
pitch it
as well
that's that's really really funny you
know that would make a really funny
sketch though
that would and that would really make a
really funny snl sketch or i could see
that in um if tim uh uh i think you
should leave on netflix could be a fun
schedule yeah yeah or we just shoot it
next week yeah or we just shoot
calling all fat shoes
how do we get how do we find these fat
dogs these fat jewishes
the fat jewish
it's new york there's got to be fat ones
there's got to be right oh yeah
i like that i like that but anyway yeah
one was a pool with me with uh ten
thousand goldfish
oh that i think you well you might drown
scoop them out no yeah yeah they don't
buy it they don't bite i know but it'd
be an exercise i'd have to get ten 000
out yeah that would suck that would be
that's just that's really on you your
state of physical fitness at that point
i don't think there's a threat from the
goldfish yeah yeah but i could die of
exhaustion um you could and then you'll
drown 10 000 you know and i don't know
who knows what happens when they get
together in the school
yeah they might yeah my kids are crazy
i've seen pixar they might be out there
that's why i actually wanted to show you
this these ants uh teamed up together in
a swarm and attacked a wasp's nest
that's wow bad ass
yeah badass bad ass so so bad answers
that's not sorry they're not
they're not crawling on anything they're
that's themselves they created a bridge
you're kidding me
they're smart man and how are they
fighting the bees they're raiding the
nests and ripping the honey out and
walking back up the bridge
well the bees aren't the bees aren't
fighting back we're about to see look
the bees are all pissed off you see them
oh those are the ones crawling over
there so that whole bridge is just ants
just ants like all
yo
whoa
and but what's in the center it's just
ants holding hands yeah
wow like hands across america exactly
well i know that they do that ants like
work as teams i know but i've never seen
a 10-foot rope made of ants yeah
by the way speaking of ants
the other day
i had an ant problem in the house so we
put down an ant trap and then my 10
month old daughter ate the antrap like
eight like there was poison and i called
poison control we were terrified i
called poison control and poison control
was just some guy who could barely speak
english that picked up the phone from
his house they outsourced poison again
he goes poison control and i could hear
his kids screaming three one one no i
just googled poison control and dialed a
num the number for poison controls like
a one eight seven seven or one eight
hundred numbers okay and they outsource
poison control and this guy had me on
the phone for 10 minutes he was just
googling what to do if a person if a kid
eats the ant trap of the company that i
gave him and then he after 10 minutes he
was like yeah it's not enough poison for
it to uh do anything to a human but i
was like how are they outsourcing poison
control what what is it that she ate
it's a so it's a it's a what it is is
it's a poison thing that's poisonous to
ants
it's a liquid and an ant will go
take the liquid back to the queen and
then once it kills the queens all the
ants die
or the game of thrones the ants move on
yeah and so my daughter
thought she was an aunt
and she took a sip of it oh my god dude
dude i turned my back for one heart
attack i turned my back for one second
to eat magic spoon and and i and and
then next thing you know
next you know promo code uh hey babe or
chaos five dollars off your first order
um
i
i uh no honestly though were you having
a heart attack a heart attack a heart
attack because i thought she tricked
your poison i mean we
ran her right over to the sink started
washing her mouth out but you said that
it doesn't kill the ants it kills the
ants it's not a harmful enough it's not
a large amount why wouldn't the ant that
ate it die he has enough time to get
back to the queen somehow he brings it
back to the queen yeah almost like that
uh i know what that's like you ever see
that powder that white powder that's
okay killed bugs no no it's like that
that
acid or whatever boric acid okay it's
what
sermon is used and they they eat it and
they store it and they go back to the
their friends and they they're like i
got food for you and then everybody dies
everybody dies yeah that's what i think
happens
in this uh in this ant family but the
ant colonies of ants like right now this
is a very clean pristine home right now
you might have thousands of ants in the
walls there's ants everywhere really i
told you if you put all these wouldn't
they show themselves eventually if you
put all the insects on a scale and all
the humans on the scale the insects
weigh about 10 times more than the
humans more than 8 billion humans more
than 8 billion humans the insects weigh
10 times more and they are
10 000 times lighter
wow that's wild wow dude average insect
is three milligrams
average weight of a person is 60
kilograms i don't know milligrams of
kilograms we're in the united states the
weight of the world's insect population
is about 70 times i'm sorry seven zero
times that of its human population so
the insects weigh
more
than what's eight times
more than 70 times there you go
what's
the weight of 8 billion people times 70.
it's
what do you mean
i'm trying to think of how how much they
weigh if they weigh more than 70 times
all humans combined there's 8 billion
humans so whatever that weight is they
weigh 70 times more than that well let's
see which is seven thousand percent yeah
i'm gonna say i'm going to tell you here
let's say this you can't even that
number won't come out on your calculator
i'm going to just say the average human
let's just say the average that was real
that's not real that one on the left is
holding that no here hold on eight
billion
oh i can't even my calculator only goes
up to 800 million i'm saying well let's
say 800 million
times i'm going to just say one two
three siri she'll do it
she'll she'll do it siri
hey siri hey siri
how come it doesn't do it hey siri
hey
siri oh hey
hey siri
nothing siri you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
oh my god what is that
oh i mean come on he in the character
that's bigger than the chihuahua that
bug the thing is eating a full grown
carrot
the whole carrot is in this bug's mouth
like he's a human being that's an ant
the bug is as big as a gerbil
and loves carrots i wonder if he loves
butt if you saw a bug as big as a gerbil
i'll tell you right now one of two
things is happening one of three things
what is it if i don't have a bomb
shelter to live in
okay oh god i hate bugs oh if i don't
have bugs traffic sweat the common cold
strong wind bugs bugs is my fifth most
hated thing bugs uh if i can't move to a
bomb shelter and i cannot escape
a bug like that
i'm drinking the poison myself that's
what i'm doing i'm drinking the poison
myself
well so you don't think you can win so
you look at the size of that [ __ ] so
who would win in a fight then you or a
room full of 10 000 bugs
oh the bugs win
100 percent you did 10 000 but what all
sizes or these big bugs just
let's say
let's say you have the bugs is it an
assortment it's about one of them flies
it's like a it's like a it's like a
trail mix of bugs yeah but it could be
from the smallest to the biggest
look at that
you guys might see this five inch five
inch giant water bug this is the ten
biggest bugs apparently okay this is a
giant water bug that's
four and a half inches
so a giant water bug at just as big as
homeless pimp's penis
is 560 billion
there you go
so 506 could have done that math 560
billion pounds no times 70. that's eight
times seven that's eight billion times
seven oh that's 56 billion okay she's
right so serious here's right so
the bugs weigh 560
no i'm sorry the bugs weigh as much as
560 billion humans
so if a human
is what's the average you want to say
150 pounds that's what i said yeah hey
siri what is 560 billion times 150 bird
dogs you know about these shirts do you
know about these shorts bird dogs bro
i've been wearing i swear to god look at
my trip in puerto rico i wore bird dog
shorts almost every day they are the
best i know shorts they got the
underwear lining inside the shorts
shorts they fit me fantastic i can't
explain to you how much i seriously love
bird dogs if you're a guy or
transitioning to be a guy or if you just
whatever if you love shorts bird dogs i
don't even feel like i need to buy
underwear anymore i feel like i know the
inside of softly i love them it's almost
like they're like uh comfortable like
basketball shorts running shorts with
the with the interior in it it's almost
like blew me away it's almost like i'm
putting on shorts and then there's just
a to the touch soft there's a soft hands
holding my nuts in place that's so true
and if you can get them right now if you
go to birddogs.com that's b r d d s dot
com enter promo code hey babe they're
gonna throw in a free bird dog's dad hat
that's birddogs.com promo code hey babe
and boom a free bird dogs dad hat with
your pair of bird dogs get you
downstairs ready for summer with bird
dogs you will not take these things off
i promise you dude
i know you've been working out lately
thank you uh i i could tell and i know
it takes a lot i know sometimes you you
leave the house to go to an instructor
right uh you go to a yoga instructor i
hate it so much and you have to i love
yoga i just hate having to leave you go
to the gym and everything it could be
tough i don't have the time to do that i
got a peloton
and now i'm getting my workouts in and
the convenience of my home but it's
better than going the one thing i didn't
like about working out at home was that
it was just kind of like boring but with
with peloton they had the online classes
all different instructors music
intensities you personalize it to
yourself you could take rides through
areas like that you've never seen before
it just makes you feel like you're
either outside or amongst other people
and you still get motivated yeah from
the instructors so it's awesome we
picked one up last fall it's changed how
i how i approach exercising i i think
it's i think it's great they go ahead
tip no i was going to say every time
i've went on a peloton i've loved it
yeah i've loved it it's fun and you can
also you don't have to just do the bike
you could turn to have a treadmill too
but you could also turn the screen and
you could just take classes like
aerobics classes and uh intensity yoga
classes i was gonna say and they have
strength training they have everything
teloton is like literally that's all you
need is peloton yeah experiment with new
types of movement judgment free at home
at a level and pace that feels good for
you again cycling strength training yoga
running you're more likely to stick to a
workout you enjoy so peloton makes every
class fun and that is true their
instructors are awesome uh it feels like
you're hanging out with friends nothing
gets you moving like the perfect song
and every peloton class is set to a bomb
ass playlist uh maybe you're looking for
a 10-minute upper body stretch between
calls or a 40-minute run before bed they
do it all it works with your schedule
whether you have five minutes or an hour
plus you'll never have an awkward
encounter in the locker room again so i
guess right now is the perfect time to
try a peloton i can't imagine right
peloton bike plus is now 500 less best
price they've had just yet uh including
free delivery and setup and there are
more game changing prices available on
the original peloton bike and the
peloton tread visit one onepeloton.com
to learn more one
o n e peloton.com to learn more
560 billion times 150 is 8.4 times 10 to
the 13th power
yo she doesn't even have a word for it
wow she had to spit back just that's how
heavy bugs are it's 84
with it's the number 84 with 12 zeros
after it is how how heavy the bugs are
if i did that right my god
that's as much
elon musk that's he they got elon musk's
weight yeah that's crazy
that's crazy wow here we go an atlas
beetle also known as a choco colomosa
it's 5.1 inches
yeah you got to show these p this is
insane we're gonna put it up that
thing's got a goddamn
horns
what does it do all day
what does it do all day
it's got horns is it jewish
oh my
yeah cut that part out i'm just kidding
just want to do a dad joke
what dad
mine
yeah my dad's name's adolf
yeah oh my hercules
every one of these huge bugs is also
just so happens to be absolutely
terrifying disgusting i mean a 6.7 inch
beetle this has to be like in a rain far
somewhere right this is why i don't go
to the rainforest yeah but backyard
dinosaurs weren't the bugs supposed to
be like oh my god cars yeah dinosaurs
though
it seems like beetles are the biggest
bug
could you just step on one of these
things with your shoes still i don't
know i feel like it would be like that's
you'd have to get a new shoe this thing
the largest insect on earth go back up
to that name uh pimpy please uh
friggan strea chanesis zao
24.6 inches the largest insects on on
earth so it's two feet guys holding his
hands
looks like an asparagus it looks like a
it looks like a tree branch with legs
oh god yeah if i saw any one of those
things the largest insect that ever
lived was a mega mega
neuroprocess permiana it's basically a
it's basically a dragonfly the size of a
chihuahua yes it's a dragonfly bigger
than chihuahua yeah it's a flying
chihuahua dragonfly i'm assuming that's
a mock-up of it yeah yeah yeah now what
would you do if you were sleeping one
night and that was on you
no that's it i'm telling you right now i
i don't know what i would do i don't
know what i would do could you rather
deal with that or a rat
could you deal with an insect or a roof
so you're saying one is gonna wake you
up crawling over a long bug or a rat or
rat one is going to wake you up crawling
all over your body you're going to be
strapped down to a bed you have to deal
with it for five minutes which one is it
that's a tough call bro that's why we do
on hey rats freak me out mice don't rats
do yeah
people people breed and have rats as
pets and they don't necessarily attack
you
so
i i don't know man i'm gonna tell you
something disgusting right now
when i
when i was doing that gig with the bald
eagle by the way the bald eagle got paid
more than me rightfully so when i was
doing that gig the handler by the way
for all you bald eagles out there just
go to keeps use the promo code hey babe
that's what it is
prevent it's all about prevention yeah
um
you
um
uh
the bald eagle
the handler was feeding it food and i
said what is that like meat they go yeah
it's uh meat then you know we slice it
up back at where we you know where we
are
so what kind of meat is that where this
is going and he goes uh she goes um she
goes it's rat me yeah she goes we get
the frozen rats and then i slice them up
i slice them up and that's how the eagle
likes it i said that's rap meat she goes
yeah she goes smell it i go i don't want
to smell it she goes no smell it it's
going to smell like something really
familiar
and i said
what is it and she goes just smell it
she goes i'm not going to mess with you
i said please don't like you know i'll
throw up she does
smell it she goes what's the first thing
that comes to your mind when you smell
this handful of wraps like butterscotch
or something mcdonald's
it smells like you knew it right away
you said it you were like this smells
like fast food it smells like mcdonald's
she literally smelled it and i audibly
went
i'm loving it you're kidding me yep and
she was like yep that's it yep she
didn't even laugh why does it smell like
mcdonald's she said i don't know she's
like who knows why it does smell like
mcdonald's she goes but this is
un
i didn't change anything about this rat
this is how all 100 of the rats smell
when you slice up their bodies they all
smell like mcdonald's they're probably
in so many mcdonald's that yeah it just
gets on them it's like you ever eat fast
food like oh i smell like mcdonald's
or mcdonald's doesn't smell at all
there's just so many rats in it and
mcdonald's smells like rats that's what
it's mcdonald's if you'd like to sponsor
us let us know we'd love to get if
you're watching wrong babe ronald if
you're watching you know that y'all and
we know that you are yeah
that reminds me of uh sergio chacon
keeps frozen rats he has a separate
freezer
so i know because i was gonna ask you a
moment ago
how do you get a frozen rat and for what
reason sergio chacon gets them on amazon
sergio chacon his family will like his
wife will open up the fridge or the
freezer to cook get out of dinner and
we'll have to move over frozen
rat bod dead rat bodies that can't and
you and people snakes for his snakes and
people talk to talk to me about my
frozen goldfish
one frozen goldfish
gross you keep in the freezer sergio
chacon right now has frozen rats that he
feeds to his snakes but i thought snakes
only eat live red live animals i don't
know he feeds them frozen frozen rats so
someone's killing the rats
they're not finding a dead rat and
freezing it they're killing the rats so
let me ask you a question
do they kill the rat by freezing it
alive do they have to inject the rat so
the rat dies and then they put in the
freezer or
like how is the rat getting from living
to frozen can we investigate
let's see that's a good question making
frozen rats to feed pythons gassing oh
they gas them oh
my god oh my god that is wild that ain't
good let's see
i can't believe that we were like how
does that happen and there's a tutorial
yeah on youtube they look these are the
rats that are oh they're all live right
now and now they're about to be gassed
to be made is that a box full of dead
rats to his left that has to be was that
a box full of dead rats right bodies to
his life picking them up alive no no no
he just went pick them up without a
glove rewind rewind a little bit there's
a brown box to his left go to the
beginning a little bit
scroll back a little bit
at one point to his left
there's a box right before we got to
this part no no this looks like me and
sal if we never did podcasting
was that a box a full box of dead rats
it looked like it might have been the
size of a
right there
that's what that is yes no no no no no
in between see right there oh yeah it
could be
it's so funny you never know what's on a
fedex truck yeah you never know we
probably have gotten dude those are rats
that's just a brown
cardboard box that's about four feet
high filled to the top with dead rats
let's see what happens let's see do they
get they so they fully gas them this is
atrocious but i mean i guess what are
they gonna do but where are they getting
the rats where is he getting them from
to begin with
people are breeding them to be killed
look at them and he's br and he puts
them in a box
he puts them in a in a plastic box and
they're all jumping around this has to
be um oh my god it has to be it has to
be humane no they we wouldn't be able to
get a lot better than what we
investigated on taste buds which is in
germany they send all the pet check
their little chicks yeah they just put
them on a conveyor belt that leads to
like a big grinder yeah
and then they just push them in the
grinder they just kill them you may see
now like he's putting a tube in this
thing oh this is gassing it
oh
but what's the alt okay this is horrible
oh what's the alternative oh don't have
a pet snake
[Laughter]
oh no
yeah wild dude
they're all
but how do you do this and not have like
bad dreams yeah it's horrible that
they're doing this to them
also where does life take you that this
is the career yeah
this guy he messes with reptiles so you
see his shirt so if you're all about
that reptile life
yeah it was funny though at sergio's
house i photographed the this whole
snake thing he has and he's like yeah my
wife got mad and made me buy a separate
freezer and they opened up the rat
freezer just to the top with rats how
many snakes does he have he has like i
think like 10. yeah he's got awesome you
try to break into sergio chico's house
you're going to realize very quickly he
picked the wrong house he's got over 10
snakes a pit bull
like six cats
he's a professional or almost
professional boxer yeah you're getting
messed up one way you just picked the
wrong house and you're going to realize
very quickly yeah it's so hilarious to
visit him because you're like having
cereal at a table and the whole wall is
snakes yeah my niece uh my niece had a
full room she had a two bedroom
apartment and
one bedroom was a complete completely
dedicated to snakes and reptiles
all four walls cages it looked like
literally looked like a pet store in her
home she had i i wanted i want to say
this dozens of snakes and she would hold
them she'd take them out
white ones long ones [ __ ] six foot
ones two foot ones and she feeds them
all this stuff too and she just just
to walk around the house holding snakes
and what do the snakes do that she's got
to be a miserable life for the snake
just whole life is in a box i don't know
i really don't know they always seem
miserable
yeah what's the snake really doing
what's this
all the tick is doing is either hunting
or not right it's either got uh it's
either got something in its belly that's
like the same shape as it yeah as it was
prior in his day a snake is either
digesting or hunting or shedding like
there's no hanging out
a snake's going to do a podcast no but a
snake's not even going to hang do snakes
socialize the way their other animals
socialize like snakes have sex lives
there's no socialization with snakes
right there's not like a group of snakes
hanging out like you know how like a
pack of deer or elephant or even tigers
or whatever like snakes aren't doing
that with each other no there are
actually snakes are good
uh oh no no
they're not no they yeah they're not
that solitary creatures that come
together the mate and hibernate and not
much else okay
wait not stay alone
not so
not so garter snakes the harmless
serpents that live throughout north
america now they're surprisingly social
it says
oh okay oh they did get friends it's
garter snakes i always thought it was
garden snakes i always thought it was
garden snakes like g-a-r-d-e-n
yeah that's garter
i guess so
so that means is it not your is it
garbage you know i've heard people say
garter
i i don't know seriously is it the olive
gardener
yeah you know yeah seriously is it the
rose gardener
what about what are you taking off the
bride's like a garden or a carter i
don't know
it's kind of questions we asked yet
today um i've heard people say goder and
i'm always like i don't know if that's
right and it is
yeah no they have friends it says
so they have friends too
what do they do could joel about
who does that does anybody even do that
to enter an email to continue reading do
people do that i don't know
sound off in the comments if you do that
sound no we never ask people to do
subscribe like and share please i think
it goes a long way we never asked if we
said it like everybody else on our
sign-offs for 80 episodes straight i
think we'd have a significant amount
more followers and subscribers because
people don't think it you know subscribe
like and share this podcast the hay bay
podcast there it is especially on itunes
go to itunes itunes itunes is big i know
i've been ready
and share it you know go to itunes and
on on on youtube if you listen to our
podcast every week and even if you don't
watch it or if you do watch it and
you're not subscribed go to no press and
hit the subscribe button let's see if we
how many we jumped now i know you love
light lightsabers yeah so i thought this
would interest you this is cool did you
see this no a nate the u.s navy shot
down a drone using a laser beam for the
first time in history of these or
freaking lasers on that's sick if we can
start using lasers is that a real photo
no that's real that that's they caught
the laser hitting it yeah well they knew
it was coming [ __ ]
shot down a drone with a sophisticated
heat beam which they call a laser
like they made that name i hope they put
this on uh the airports because all the
drones are delaying flights now are they
yeah is that why you're flying is that
why flights are getting delayed a lot of
uh flights are just getting canceled
because of gas prices
wow they're just canceling them in the
future they're like really we know we're
not gonna pay we ain't paying for gas
for that flight we ain't paying for that
laguardia at the freaking atlanta gas
prices well they don't want it because
they're not going to sell a ticket that
expensive
yeah justify it they're not going to be
able to justify it so what do we got we
got to do now drive you got to drive you
got to drive to the bahamas i get that
light underground tunnel yeah well uh
elon musk is is starting to work on his
hyper loop yeah uh coming out in like
what they say two three weeks he's gonna
start with the microphone
look at this so there's a guy on the
road and he passed the car he passed a
driver and a guy in a tesla who's not
driving and is asleep
two people asleep at the wheel in the
front seat both people asleep head
slouched down the car is driving on the
expressway
right
scary also uh elon announced in 2024
driverless ubers will launch yeah
robot taxi without a drive like without
a steering wheel no you're getting in
one of those yeah let's do it in what
year
2024
are you gonna get any one of those i
don't think so a car pulls up no human
in it you getting in it no you aren't
don't you in manhattan i'll do it what
are they really gonna hit
my thing is not not only it's not that
it's just like it could be there's no i
have literally zero control which i know
i have zero control with someone driving
at least as human being i can
incapacitate them if they're going crazy
or do something communicate to them
communicate
i bet you they'll come back with their
rebuttal and say this is safer than
human error
like it's even safer than than driving
with a human
yeah you know what i mean
yeah i mean i will say this the car
won't smell
yeah and it won't try to talk to you
yeah
yeah it will it won't ask you to it
won't tell you that the credit card
machine is down so you have to pay in
cash but will you have to tip
what are you going to tip
out of respect what am i going to do
it's kind of nutty because as soon as
the car pays for itself it's 100 profit
right you know so what's he saying he's
gonna put a fleet of self-driving cars
into uber yeah but why why then you're
taking business away from people you're
taking because that's probably he'd
probably argue it's safer and less
people die
nah you're taking jobs away though
i mean he also believes that all jobs
are going to go away in the next like 20
years what do you mean they're going to
go away like robots can do everything
yeah so what are people going to do
that's why he wants universal income
he's a big proponent of the universal
income elon musk really yeah
he wants everyone because he's like
there's going to be no already you're
starting to see a lot of jobs
we live in a capitalist society i know
what what does he want to do
i don't like communism just give
everybody money i don't know subsidize
maybe
he just it's not as simple as like
everybody makes x amount
that'll never happen yeah yeah i don't
know i have dude i have no idea i think
it's gonna become people just start
destroying robots at a protest
yeah yeah you think that people were
like yo they're taking our jobs and
it'll just be like a war of the worlds i
do yeah wow world war z this is getting
apocalyptic this episode well we're
having fun talking about violence and we
gotta we gotta move to these colombian
towns would you travel to to the next
town like this honestly
this is real
what is she on what is she on she's on
uh on a um what do you call that it's
like a stool that hangs on this wire and
what is that wire what are those things
called a zip line a zip line
i wouldn't do that no there are two
ropes one zip line before but i'm not
height no way no way
no way
even children in backpacks are
transported across the cable which is
about 50 years old there are two ropes
one going and one coming back which are
fixed they use makeshift harness and a
crotch to give them direction everything
from food to small animals and even
children in a backpack are transported
across the cable which is about 50 years
old
it's all fun and games until one child
in a backpack goes flying off of that
thing that's it that's it and then they
have to switch it to we have not had an
accident in
one day yeah
zero days they don't have local news
there
yeah they're probably not reporting the
backpacks that went down well i mean
that thing's been there for 50 years
we're only hearing about it now let me
ask you a question i put my kid in a
backpack i need my kid to get down to
that area real fast for some reason i
throw my kid in the backpack i push him
bald eagle comes by
that thing's
the kid is 500 feet near a bald eagle
just swoops by takes the kid
what am i supposed to do you know how
many eagles and hawks and and the like
are in or in that canyon that they were
just that's why i'm that is why one of
the reasons why i'm starting my daughter
yesterday started in mma because at
least she'll know mma to somehow be able
to fight off if she gets the if she gets
the eagle in full guard then she can
ground and pound that's kind of what i
was thinking about myself yeah she
starts grappling that [ __ ] eagle yeah
she puts it in a in a beak lock or
something like a talon lock 100
this has been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey